-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy-nominated actress
for her work on
"Orange is the New Black."
She stars in the
limited series "Pam & Tommy,"
which is now streaming in
its entirety on Hulu.
Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
Taylor Schilling, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-I always feel like
I'm seeing my best friend.
My best TV friend.
-I mean, you're one of our more
frequent guests on this show.
But it's been three years
since we've seen
each other in person.
We've done some Zoom,
but it's great to see you
in person again.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
As always,
you have a way with words.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-One of the things we
talked about during the pandemic
is that you started
suffering from narcolepsy,
which is a very serious
condition that just seems funny
--
it's funny when
it happens to you.
-Yeah. I mean, I don't want to
make fun of people who have --
Narcolepsy is awful.
-Yeah, I can only imagine.
-I fall asleep a lot.
It's weird. I'm getting older.
I don't know what's happening
all the time to me.
-So it is still happening.
-No, no.
It's less,
except when I'm in cars.
-That's maybe the worst
time for it to happen.
-Yeah.
-Not driving.
-Okay, good. Okay.
-When I'm in a passenger seat
or in the back,
I feel very
relaxed and I fall asleep.
-I think that's okay, though.
-Yeah, I think it's okay.
-I think,
again, as we get older,
I would like to be
sleeping more in general.
-Yeah. That picture of the bowl
on top of
-And he's like,
"Oh, everybody will love it."
And I'm like, "You're a bad kid.
[ Laughter ]
You're a bad kid.
You're a liar."
Well, I'm mostly just glad
that you've recovered from that,
because that must have
been scary.
-It was. You know, I'm confused.
It's, like, a healthier
coping mechanism than others.
Do you know what I mean?
-Oh, that's interesting. Yeah.
-I think it's I'd I prefer that
if I'm like, "Okay, crisis,"
I fall asleep, as opposed to
doing something else.
-Yeah. Well,
I guess it's a way of, like,
shutting you down
before you can maybe, like,
do your worst instincts.
-Right. Yeah.
Exactly. Exactly.
It's helpful.
I don't have time for my
worst instincts anymore.
-No. It's just better to
sleep it off.
-I'm an adult. Yeah.
-You're of an adult back
in New York City.
We've talked a lot about
when you were younger.
Your early apartments
in New York were pretty gnarly.
And now you're back.
You know, obviously,
your career has been met with
a fair amount of success.
I'm assuming you've got
a great pad right now.
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah, so, I was --
Yeah, so, It's been
a hard transition for me
back to New York.
-Okay.
-I got to my apartment.
I thought -- You know, in the
theme of trying to work against
my lower instincts,
I thought, "It's 3:30.
I'll take a bath."
You know, I put the dog --
I gave the dog water.
I'm going to drink some water.
It's been a long time.
-Since you've had water?
-Yes! Well, yes.
It's been a long time since
I've been in a studio.
-Oh, interesting.
-So --
[ Laughter ]
So, I was like, "Okay,
I'm going to take a bath."
And I had -- I ran a bath.
I was like -- I took 10 minutes
and I thought,
"Okay, I'll go away for
10 minutes,
and the bath will fill up."
And then, I got back,
and it was cold water.
So I was like, "[Bleep], this
place doesn't have hot water.
Okay, whatever.
You know, New York."
-Right.
-And I thought, "Alright."
And I drained it.
And then I was
like, "What the [bleep]"
And I was like, "Did I leave
a faucet on downstairs?"
And then I walked downstairs,
and the water was --
The bathtub was draining through
a light fixture
on the first floor.
And I thought,
"I can't live this way."
But I've been living
this way my whole life.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter
what the apartment --
And it's a nice place.
-It's a nice place.
Can I make one -- Please don't
take this as a criticism.
-Oh, God.
What should I have done?
-Well, I think when
you're like, "I ran a bath,
and I gave it 10 minutes,"
I think that's too much
time to leave a bath alone.
-Oh, [bleep]
-Yeah.
I mean, I think that,
more often than not,
ends with, like,
water from a light fixture.
-Problems. Yeah.
That's actually --
That's a good point.
Maybe that's too long.
-Also, you sent us
a video of something
that happened in your apartment.
And I would say
I'm pretty easygoing.
I think if stuff goes wrong
in an apartment,
I could live with it
pretty well.
I'm not sure I'd be able to
handle this.
-Yeah.
-And your dog is in this
video, as well, Tank.
-Yeah.
-Tank seems okay with it.
-Tank is like, "Why?
Why do I have to --"
-I like to think you're making
a video of this,
and Tank is looking at you,
saying,
"You need to get on the phone
with who you rented
this place from."
-Yes.
-Let's take a look at the video.
-[ Chuckles ] Tank.
-So, those are just the lights.
That's what the lights
were doing.
-She looked so scared.
-Well, who wouldn't look scared?
-It's so crazy.
I wanted to make sure
that they knew.
Well, okay, so, the water
came through the light fixture,
and then I tried again
to take a bath.
And then they had fixed it,
and then the water
came through a closet.
And then, later that night,
I tried to use
the dimmer switch,
and that started happening.
I'm still there.
-You're still in the apartment?
-Yeah.
-What do you think the breaking
point will be with the place?
-I don't know. I don't know.
-Yeah.
They must think you're the
best tenant they've ever had.
-I guess so.
-How is Tank, in general?
-She's doing well.
-Yeah.
-I think she's aging
into this sort of space of,
"I understand this world
better than you do."
Like that vibe of her just
sitting there kind of like,
"Alright, this is what
you're going to do right now.
Cool."
-I want to talk about
your fantastic new show.
Will you stick around, please?
-Of course. Thank you.
-Alright, you guys,
we'll be right back
with more from Taylor Schilling.